our delegation from Al Jazeera is at the
international criminal court right now
these are live pictures you're looking
at from the hey the team handing over
paperwork related to the killing of its
correspondent Shireen abuakla this is
live now from the Hague Rob mcbray
Robert McBride is live for us in
occupied East Jerusalem uh so Rob just
give us a little bit more uh on what
we're expected to uh to see happen here
yeah this is uh handing over some of the
case work that has been gathered in the
months uh since the killing some of the
evidence surrounding shireen's killing
and handing it over to representatives
of the international criminal court
there'll also be a news conference being
held later today by the Al Jazeera
delegation really to outline and explain
why they believe that the international
criminal court could and should be
holding their own investigation into
this killing there it is being closely
followed from here in Jerusalem and also
in the occupied West Bank because of
course it has been an uphill struggle to
get any kind of accountability and
Justice ever since the killing took
place on May the 11th in the occupied
West Bank Town of Janine where Shireen
was covering a raid by Israeli forces
along with other journalists she was
clearly identified on her body armor and
on her helmet as being a journalist when
she was a shot and killed and ever since
then right from the very start the
official Israeli narrative about how she
came to be shot and killed has changed
initially they started to talk about uh
maybe being caught in crossfire between
Israeli soldiers and armed Palestinians
and that maybe it was a Palestinian
bullet well that was quickly disproven
by journalists who were there and also
by independent investigations that said
there were no armed Palestinians in the
vicinity it was only Israeli soldiers
then they said they didn't know how she
came to have been shot finally it was
only in September that they came around
to admitting yes it was likely an
Israeli soldier killed Shireen but no
there would be no criminal investigation
and Rob we know as well that the U.S
Department of Justice also opened its
own investigation
into the killing
um just first of all tell us why and how
that is related in any way to this
particular case days
yeah I mean that is the Big Hope here
that this move by the United States
might bring some kind of breakthrough
this is an investigation announced by
the FBI uh they announced in
mid-november that they would be
investigating uh this case it has been
welcomed by shireen's family saying that
they hoped it would be a truly
independent investigation but it's not
clear just how this FBI investigation is
going to be conducted given that the
Israelis will not cooperate with it they
have criticized the decision they say
that they will not cooperate with this
investigation but International legal
experts have said that an investigation
like this being announced by by the FBI
they wouldn't have gone ahead with this
kind of announcement unless they thought
there was some credible evidence that
this was indeed a targeted killing other
observers have mentioned that since this
announcement that you know the with the
close diplomatic and Military link
between the United States and Israel the
United States could bring a lot of
pressure to bear on Israel to get them
to cooperate but it remains to be seen
just if the Biden Administration has
that will whether they will bring that
pressure to try to get cooperation from
the Israeli side
Rob thanks for that uh Rob McBride
Lifest there in occupied East Jerusalem
um we've been looking at a delegation
from Al Jazeera at the international
criminal court handing over the
paperwork related to the killing of
correspondent Sharina